did you ever get to the point where you
bought like uh like voice cds oh yeah
yeah wait what is it what's this
it's like um there's a lot of like
different kinds of voice
cds um out in the world um and there's
like
like there's like voice dramas and
there's also ones where they kind of
like
talk to you talk to you it's like it's
think of a think of an a
podcast except you're doing the podcast
with them and it's in like pov yeah yeah
yeah this is this because you're part of
trash
it's like an asmr thing on youtube now
so i guess they made it yeah yeah
yeah and um they use like but they act
as those characters yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um they also have um
like they have these microphones
um yeah and it's kind of like it's
shaped like a person's face
uh the binaural ones yeah yeah and then
they use that to take
um some of the audio so it's like
sometimes you hear the audio from the
right side
and it kind of seems like they're there
oh it's like the asmr
yeah yeah yeah norman made a mic
and it's literally like a foam head yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's super [ __ ] expensive yeah it's
really [ __ ] weird yeah as well
because you're talking into like a fake
head yeah it looks really
weird but it's like but it's yeah so
for i think decades now these like voice
actors do these like
drama cds where they were like for
example like you know
romeo park would do one of his and it's
like if hitsugayo was like hanging out
with you
like if you were on a date with this
particular character and they were like
they would play out these scenarios in
pov all right if you were in that
position and like people would just like
listen to it
yeah i mean i've seen like some of the
short anime
that have that i kind of like that where
it's just like pov you have a girlfriend
it's just like every episode there's
like a different girl literally
dora the explorer because like i've seen
some where they're like they would say a
line and then they kind of pause for a
couple of years
waiting for your response i think i
think i remember i love coke y'all when
when i won't finish kogyos
i need more code yeah like the story
continues in an
audio cd yeah yeah yeah yeah like a
voice
i got it and you sound like a museum
tour you know what i mean and i was like
what is this i
can't listen to this like welcome to
britannia it's like britannia was once
here
what the [ __ ] is this it's like a
lecture what is this i don't wanna
listen to this see your attackers dig
that [ __ ] up man
i've actually only bought one audio cd
in like my entire time
it was like an audio drama so like it
was it was because like it ended and i'm
just like
i need more i the manga is not doing it
for me i need to hear the voice actors
and actresses
playing out the ending of this that's
why i [ __ ] bought it and it's the
only audio drama i've bought so far
and i don't regret anything it was
amazing i think the closest i ever got
to that was i used to tune in because
like a lot of voice actors especially
like the top ones
do like radio shows yeah they do
like talking about their role in the
enemy of like you know if they like work
together
or whatever they would you know go for
like however long the anime stands for
basically so like the closest i ever got
to that was i used to like tune in every
week to
kajiyuki and shimon no hiro attack on
titan
radio and it was really cool because
like they would openly just like
kind of poke fun up the show a lot of
times as well but it's also like i mean
yeah you guys are the voices of the show
so i guess that gives you like some
credit to be like
that was kind of ridiculous wasn't it
this is still a big thing in japan the
audio
cds it is i think it's getting bigger
now like
because mp3s are easier to sell right
and i mean like like we just established
it's more about
building yourself up as like a kind of
like an idol in some cases right